I think part of the problem with the
classical media let's say trying to make
a transition to the digital age is that
they have no idea what the digital media
is like I was watching an MSNBC clip the
other day about this robot I think her
name is Sophia who who has a fairly
advanced degree of artificial
intelligence and who can manifest pretty
realistic human facial emotions and it
was a four-minute clip and at a
30-second ad at the beginning of it and
you couldn't skip the ad and I thought
there's a real arrogance on the part of
the MA MSNBC people to put that on
YouTube because anybody who's familiar
with the YouTube let's say culture knows
that well you get to put a 10-second ad
on and then you get to skip it after 5
seconds if you want like you can't ask
people to pay 30 seconds of attention
for four minutes of content it violates
the norms and so it had only had about
12,000 views and that's a really
interesting example of Marshall
McLuhan's idea that the medium is the
message right as you build a new
technological infrastructure and it's
sort of like the old thing because
YouTube is sort of like a TV network but
it's also not like a TV network at all
partly for example because when you put
something on YouTube its permanent
that's way different than broadcast TV
like it's RIT seriously revolutionarily
different and so and it's also the case
to that and then this is a strange thing
and I don't think the classic media
understands this either is that YouTube
people don't like high production values
in fact they're very cynical about them
and I think that's because they've come
to identify advanced editing and glitz
as markers that the information is
actually being manipulated which of
course it is now for better or worse I
mean editing doesn't have to be
manipulating but it certainly can be and
so and besides that a lot of the more
tech-savvy people that watch YouTube can
duplicate those sort of special effects
in their own home in half an hour so
they're not there they're no longer
markers of the kind of competence and
technological prowess that would signal
the sort of competence that you could
trust so so what YouTube viewers seem to
like is basically or
ordinary people more or less trying to
have an intelligent conversation about
something confusing and important and
the the that attention span that people
are willing to devote to that is
actually quite remarkable for for a
medium that was nothing but cute cat
videos say five years ago the fact that
like a lot of my lectures and like Joe
Rogan's podcast like three hours long
it's like what the hell people weren't
supposed to have that capacity to pay
attention in this era of fragmented
attention you know and Rogin I don't
know if you know this or not um he has a
hundred and twenty million downloads a
month now so that's 1.5 billion
downloads a year and so the last time I
saw him and that was with Brett who just
spoke I asked him what it was like to be
the most powerful interviewer the world
has ever seen because I think he
probably is if you think about it in
sheer numbers I mean maybe Walter
Cronkite back in the 60s had some
comparable influence but he said I just
don't think about it and like what what
the hell is he supposed to think about
it because no one knows what to think
about that and so he just has the
conversations and posts them and away he
goes but he has no idea what role he's
currently playing in society and we
don't have proper metrics for measuring
it and we don't understand it at all so
anyways I did these big idea lectures
with with woad ekend and they were
ranked on on the TV old channel and the
five lectures or six lectures I did all
ended up in the top 20 which really
surprised me but it was an indication
that there was something about what I
was talking about that for which there
was a market and now there's there's
some reasons for that I think you know
when I